>> Voiceover: From the Library
of Congress in Washington DC.
>> Nancy Groce: Hello,
my name is Nancy Groce,
and I'm one of the
folklorists on staff here
at the American Folklife Center
of the Library of Congress,
and I'd like to welcome you
to the latest presentation
in our ongoing Benjamin A.
Botkin's lecture series.
The Botkin series allows
us to highlight the work
of leading scholars in the
disciplines of folklore,
ethnomusicology, oral history
and cultural history while
enhancing the collections here
at the American Folklife Center.
For the center and the library,
the Botkin lectures
form an important facet
of our acquisitions' activities.
Each lecture is videotaped
and becomes part
of the permanent
collection of the center.
In addition, the lectures
are later posted as webcasts
to library's website, where
they're available for viewing
to Internet patrons
throughout the world.
So, if you haven't already done
so, now would usually go time
to turn off your cell phones.
Today, we're delighted
to be presenting a multi-faceted
event featuring the works
of our colleagues
at the influential
Philadelphia Folklore Project.
Since 1987, the staff of
the Philadelphia Folklore,
Project has worked
to sustain the vital
and diverse living cultural
heritage communities throughout
the Philadelphia region.
Through collaborative projects,
research, documentation,
and education, PFP
projects have nurtured folk
and traditional arts in the
service of social change.
Among other activities, folklore
project staff identify local
folk artists and support
their artistic growth.
They produce public programs,
advancing folk artists
and traditions significant
to Philadelphia communities,
develop educational programs
benefiting children and adults,
and document outstanding
practitioners and practices.
We're happy today to be joined
by PFP's director, folklorist,
Selina Morales, PFP's --
oh, thank you very much,
director of programs and
the cultural anthropologist
and filmmaker, Toni
Shapiro-Phim.
They will open today's
program with short overviews
of PFP's history
and accomplishments,
and then we're going to screen
PFP's latest production,
the documentary film, Because of
the War, which tells the stories
of four Liberian
women who have settled
in the Philadelphia
area, and who have drawn
on their knowledge of
traditional Liberian music
to make community,
address injustice,
and inspire action
for social change.
We are particularly honored
that one of the artists featured
in Because of the War, the
award-winning Liberian singer,
Fatu Gayflor, is able
to join us today.
During the 1970s and 80s, Ms.
Gayflor was a principal member
of Liberia's National
Cultural Troop,
the country's premier
performing arts ensemble,
and an internationally
renowned recording artist.
A US resident since
1998, Gayflor performs
at Liberian communities
throughout the country,
and since 19 -- I'm
sorry, since 2013,
has also been the
artistic director
of the Philadelphia's Liberian
Women's Chorus for Change.
Ms. Gayflor will join Selina
and Tony to introduce the film
and for a question-and-answer
session following the screening.
I would also like to
take this opportunity
to thank Nadia Kamara, the
head of Diaspora Affairs Office
at the Liberian Embassy, and
her colleague, Vicki Ward,
for joining us this
afternoon, as well as,
the members of the Catholic
League Immigrants Network,
who are concerned with
Liberia, for joining us.
And we're honored that Ms.
Kamara will take a few minutes
to welcome us, in a minute.
In addition, I want to recognize
Marita Harper, the Liberian
and African specialist
here at the Library
of Congress's Ahmed Division.
So, thank you all for coming.
So, if I can ask Ms. Kamara
to come up and say a few words
of welcome, that
would be lovely.
Thank you so much for coming
[ Applause ]
>> Nadia Kamara:
Thank you very much.
My name is Nadia Kamara
from the embassy of Liberia.
Oh, like this, okay.
Madame [inaudible]
and all the members
of the American Folklife Center
of the Library of Congress,
distinguished ladies and
gentlemen, I stand here today
on behalf of Her Excellency,
Ambassador Lois Lewis Brutus,
Ambassador of the Republic of
Liberia, to the United States
of America, who is presently
at another engagement,
and would have loved
to be here today,
and who extends her greetings
and appreciation to the Library
of Congress for hosting
and screening the recently
completed documentary
on the war in Liberia.
In this regard, I wish
to applaud the Philadelphia
Folklore Project for producing
such a relevant documentary
film, Because of the War,
which tells the story
of four Liberian women
who have been using their
music and their talents
to address injustice and inspire
action for social injustice
and social change
for their country.
The Republic of Liberia is
particularly blessed and honored
by the contributions of our
own Liberian women artists,
who have been promoting Liberian
and African culture and music
and entertainment
throughout the world.
On behalf of the ambassador,
Her Excellency, Lois Brutus,
I want to thank and congratulate
the four Liberian women
who have used their music
to address injustice
and inspire action
for social change.
As survivors of the Liberian
Civil War, these four women,
who are accomplished
singers and models
and among other qualities have
achieved another [inaudible]
production of this film.
In this connection,
it is our hope
that this film will
create awareness
about the tragedy resulting
from Liberian Civil War
and also create a positive
impact regarding the triumph
of the human spirit
over adversity.
We also hope that the
Philadelphia Folklore Project
and other programs that
promote traditional music
and entertainment will lend
support to more African culture
and artistic practices
throughout the world.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Nancy Groce: Thank you
very, very much, Mrs. Kamara.
I'd like to, again,
welcome you to the Botkin --
this Botkin lecture,
in particular,
that celebrates the
landmark contributions
of the Philadelphia
Folklore Project,
and notes the great impact
PFP activities have had
in sustaining community
culture and artistic practices.
I ask you to join me
in welcoming PFP's
director, Selina Morales.
[ Applause ]
>> Selina Morales:
Good afternoon.
Thank you, Nancy, and the staff
at the American Folklore Center
for inviting the Philadelphia
Folklore Project to talk today
as part of the Botkin Lecture
Series, and thank you to all
of you for attending this
afternoon during [inaudible].
Today we want to tell you
about our organization,
the Philadelphia
Folklore Project.
We're impactful,
politically grounded,
and artistically excellent
projects are incubated
and presented in the
City of Philadelphia,
and we'll talk specifically
about two initiatives,
one we'll tell you about,
and the second, you'll learn
about through our latest
film Because of the War,
followed by discussion with
the filmmaker, a Q&A that is
with the filmmaker and with our
special guest, Fatu Gayflor.
We're hoping that by sharing
insights, both into the mission
and workings of our organization
and into its impacts,
you will be inspired to think
about aspects of our approach
and practice that you
might emulate, or adapt,
in the context in
which you are working
and simply being with others.
We are also hoping that this
presentation will affirm for you
that traditional
arts are, indeed,
contemporary tools -- sure.
Can folks hear me?
>> Female: Yes.
>> Selina Morales: Yeah?
Okay. Then I'm going
to keep going.
That folk -- there we go.
That folk and traditional
arts are, indeed,
contemporary tools
providing pathways forward,
that they are future-looking
and that it is their relevance
and their ability to change
and respond to social needs
that makes traditional
arts extremely potent,
powerful, and political.
The Philadelphia Folklore
Project is one of just a handful
of independent, freestanding
nonprofit organizations
dedicated folklore, Folklife,
and traditional arts nationwide.
The organization was founded
by Debora Kodish in 1987
at the 100th anniversary of
the American Folklore Society.
It started as an
effort, a project,
to learn about the
living cultural heritage
of Philadelphia, the city
where the American
Folklore Society was founded
and where it celebrated
its centennial year.
Early efforts included
massive amounts
of ethnographic fieldwork,
documentation
of community vitality, community
gardens, family reunions,
mom-and-pop shops,
street festivals.
Dr. Kodish and the team of
Folklore Project staff kept
that project going,
kept our project going,
and advanced major initiatives
that documented, supported,
and helped to sustain a wide
breath of cultural knowledge
and outstanding arts
in Philadelphia.
Examples of that documentation
in the projects include 20 years
of attention to Philadelphia's
African
and African-American dance
and drum communities,
including major work
with Odunde,
one of the nation's
oldest African-American
street festivals.
We documented Cambodian arts,
African-American tap dance,
Chinese arts and culture,
Philadelphia-based Eastern
European klezmer music,
Mung food ways, and much more.
Many of these initiatives are
even carried forward today.
The Folklore Project's long-term
initiatives have left an
indelible mark on
the city's landscape,
including through our
work in a K to 8 school,
the Folk Art Culture Treasures
Charter School, founded in 2009,
as a collaboration between
Asian Americans United
and our organization.
This is a school that centers
home culture and knowledge
in the classroom and
connects 500 students
to traditional arts, as a way
of incorporating ethics, values,
and of course, aesthetics
into the school environment.
Nowadays, as Nancy said, at the
Philadelphia Folklore Project,
we identify local folk artists
and support their
artistic growth.
We produce public programs,
advancing folk artists
and traditions significant
to Philadelphia communities.
We develop education programs,
benefitting children and adults,
and document outstanding
practitioners and practices.
We work directly with
traditional artists
and community-based
organizations were using tools
of social justice activism
and community-based expressive
culture to make change
that they have identified
in their own communities,
and we understand
that opportunities
to practice valued cultural
traditions enhances lives,
self-determination, and
community-add vitality.
We do this work through
long-term engagement
with individuals,
through deep listening,
employing ethnographic methods
to learn about the traditions
of those who make change
within longtime
Philadelphia-based communities,
and communities that
have just arrived.
Because of our ongoing
collaborative approach
across the city, the folklore
project has gained a fair amount
of credibility, which is really
helpful when we're looking
to start a new project.
We produce documentation
of all of our endeavors,
and over 31 years, have
built an archive of more
than 70,000 community-sourced
histories, photographs, videos,
artworks, and interviews.
We've collaborated on
dozens of exhibitions,
music and dance concerts, artist
salons, documentary films,
and magazine articles.
Our products are
widely recognized.
They garner awards,
and they are used in K
through college classrooms.
Today, we want to highlight
our collaborative practice
and describe for you a few
examples of how we work
with others to advance our
mission to sustain vital
and diverse living
cultural heritage
in the communities
in our region.
A central program at PFP
is called the Folk Art
and Social Change Residencies.
Community members, artists,
and activists advance projects
that highlight folk
arts practices
and social justice concerns.
Projects are selected
and pursued
by folklore project staff
through an assessment
of our own resources
and capacities.
We look at dollars, genres,
content area knowledge,
our language facility,
time, and community support.
The scale and timeline
are determined
by a coalition of stakeholders.
The projects are
always multidimensional.
The artists involved
advance their own skills,
their artistic practice.
They gain skills in
budgeting, in leadership,
in public speaking, exhibition
design, grant writing,
contract negotiations,
decision-making,
and relationship building, and
the residency results vary.
In addition to skills built,
often exhibitions are mounted
or an article is written,
concerts are performed,
or workshops are conducted.
Because each residency
is really distinct,
it's hard to make
generalizations
about the outcomes, but all of
our projects, at their core,
employ ethnographic and
participatory research methods,
including working with a
community advisory council
where assessment is at the
center of the practice.
We set goals together and ask
ourselves how were going all the
way along the way.
If a project is a year,
or a project is six years,
thinking constantly about
the relationship of the work
to the goals for each
of the stakeholders.
Funding for the projects,
for the Folk Art
and Social Change
residencies come principally
from the National
Endowment for the Arts,
where we take an approach
to funding this work
by funding the methodology
and the process of doing it,
rather than the particular
programs that are part of it,
and that way, as we're doing
these collaborative processes,
when we identify a thing we want
to do, a product that we want
to create, an interpretive
methodology, then we can go
for other kinds of grants
particular fundraising
for that node of the project.
I'll introduce you now to
PFP's director of programs,
Dr. Toni Shapiro-Phim.
Toni runs our Folk Arts and
Social Change residency programs
and will share with you two
examples that show our mission
at work in different ways.
So, Toni.
[ Applause ]
>> Toni Shapiro-Phim: Thank you.
The year was 2011.
Losong Semtan [assumed
spelling],
an award-winning Tibetan
artist, a sand mandala artist,
he creates images of aspects
of the Tibetan universe
out of grains of colored sand,
and he does so over the course
of days, week, or
weeks, maybe a month.
This artist told Selina
that he'd loved introduce
folklore project staff
to members of the local
Philadelphia Tibetan community.
Losong Semtan, this very artist,
had been engaged with projects
with us for years, but we
hadn't had a chance to connect
with other local
Tibetans before.
This is his work, one
of his masterpieces.
So, fast forward to
the spring of 2015.
We h ad spent four years
developing relationships
with documenting the
Philadelphia Tibetan community
comprised of about
150 people total.
Together, with members
of that community,
we created an exhibition that
chronicles a year in the life
of Philadelphia's Tibetans.
It offers a glimpse of their
commitment to their community
and to their culture,
coming together annually
to publicly call Tibet's
autonomy and deliverance
from oppression, celebrating
the Dalai Lama's birthday
and Tibetan New Year
through ritual and games.
Honoring ancestral traditions
and the struggle of those
in Tibet through
the monthly practice
of Lakher [assumed spelling] and
the weekly teaching and learning
of Tibetan language, songs, and
dances at Tibetan Sunday school.
It shares, too, how
Tibetans on a daily basis,
pay respect to the Buddha
and to the Dalai Lama
and the privacy of their homes.
The exhibition was about
to open in a small gallery
on the first floor of our office
on a springtime afternoon.
That very morning, I got a
call from a member of the board
of the Tibetan Association
of Philadelphia.
"Toni," he asked,
"would you mind
if Tibetan monks visiting
the United States from India,
monks who happen to have
just arrived in Philadelphia,
would you mind if they came
by to bless the exhibition?"
And so, it was blessed.
Now we're going to rewind a bit.
We got to the exhibition
opening after years
of building towards something.
Members of the Tibetan
Association
of Philadelphia had originally
told us that they'd love
to create an exhibition
that shares their concern
or the plight of their
homeland and for all Tibetans.
I spent at least a
year-and-a-half following
community members around
at their annual monthly
and weekly celebrations,
commemorations, and activities,
interviewing them in their
homes and photographing
and videotaping some of
the cultural practices.
Then, as part of the
exhibition development process,
we selected hundreds of
photographs have been taken
over that year and a half,
hung them from clothesline
around our then-empty
gallery, and invited everyone
in the Tibetan community
to stop by one evening.
So, that means is 70 or
80 people stopped by,
that's a huge percentage
of the entire population.
We asked people to select up to
three photographs that resonated
with them, images that meant
something to them and about
which they'd like
to say something,
and we had multiple
copies of each image
that more one person could
choose a particular picture.
We recorded interviews with
everyone, some in translation,
and it was these statements and
stories that became the captions
for the photographs
mounted in the exhibition.
While the exhibition
included material objects
and even a complete Tibetan
altar room at their urging,
it's just some of the
photographs and their captions
that we'll share with
you today before we move
on to our next project,
which is the movie.
So, there is one of the sand
mandalas by Losong Semtan.
I mentioned that members
of the Tibetan community have
prioritized educating the
broader Philadelphia population
about the situation
in their homeland.
The Chinese military invaded
Tibet in the 1950s, and in 1959,
Tibetans in their
capital, Lhasa,
rose up against Chinese rule,
and many were slaughtered.
Many who survived
were imprisoned.
The Dalai Lama, Tibetan
Buddhism's spiritual leader,
and at that time, Tibet's
political leader, as well,
escaped, ultimately establishing
a Tibetan government
in exile in India.
Thousands and thousands
of Tibetans followed him,
taking harrowing journeys
through the mountains.
I'm going to quote from
the International Campaign
for Tibet website.
"Tibetans cannot practice
their religion freely.
Nor can they protect
their culture
and language in a
meaningful way.
Instead, they suffer
from repressive laws
that deem any expression
of their identity
as extremist or even terrorist."
It's the end of the quote.
What follows is a
selection of the photographs
in the exhibition with
their captions, and for us,
it was very important to
work together to collaborate
with members of the
Tibetan communities,
so that they could tell their
story in their own words,
and we could especially
highlight how,
through the practices
of traditional arts
and other aspects of their
culture, that they nonviolently
and intentionally counter the
oppression in their homeland.
Several of the people sharing
their stories and opinions
for the exhibition chose to
remain anonymous, so that even
on the placards under
the photographs,
their names don't appear.
They're afraid of
possible repercussions
for relatives and
friends at home.
That's a tiny picture for
you to see, but I wanted
to give you a picture of the
scope of a certain issue.
On the ground there at this
commemoration of the 1959,
March 10th uprising in Tibet,
which Philadelphians do
annually, they have laid
out portraits of all the
Tibetans they have heard
of who have self-immolated.
That's they set themselves
on fire in protest
of the situation in Tibet.
And three of the people who came
to the gallery before we put the
exhibition together chose this
picture, and one them
explained, the top one,
explained that in
Tibetan Buddhism,
it's actually a sin
to commit suicide.
So, her interpretation
is that those
who have self-immolated
must be suffering so much
if this is the only option
they feel is open to them.
Here she says since 2008,
there have 136 Tibetan people
who self-immolated, but as
of yesterday, it was 153.
So, every year, the Tibetans
in Philadelphia gather in front
of the National Constitution
Center or the Liberty Bell
in Philadelphia to call
attention to both the history
and the current plight.
At that annual demonstration,
children are there,
as well as their parents, and
somebody chose this picture
for that reason, in particular.
Here, you can see father
and son both participating
in the March 10th procession,
and the son is marching
with the Tibetan flag.
That's the story for
Tibetans throughout the world.
The younger generation
is marking forward
with the Tibetan struggle.
So, every year, as I
said, they gather in March
to call attention to
the political situation,
but also every year,
they gather together
to celebrate Tibetan New
Year, which they call Losar.
I'll just redo the
first quotation.
"Losar in Tibet was very
exciting, especially for kids.
At that time, we'd count the
days until Losar came, and if,
let's say, tomorrow is Losar,
tonight we'd hardly sleep
because everyone
gets new clothes,
which you put under your pillow.
You keep looking
at the new clothes,
excited to wear them
the next day.
So, you spend most
of the night awake."
And also, at New Year time,
they engage in traditional
ceremonies,
both inside of the
Buddhist temple and outside.
This is a family, who at New
Year time, was performing
for the rest of the community.
The entire family plays musical
instruments, and somehow,
they get even their teenagers
to practice every night
for an hour altogether.
One of the family members
said that in Tibet,
they aren't allowed
to display the flag.
Nor are they allowed to display
the Dalai Lama's portrait.
So, here they are doing
that with the intention
of showing the world that
they hope someday people
in their homeland are
able to do the same.
Also, on an annual basis,
they gather to celebrate
the Dalai Lama's birthday.
Say happy birthday, have a big
cake for him, and recognize him
as even more important
than their own parents.
They get together in July
to celebrate the
Dalai Lama's birthday.
Also, in July, they participate
in Philadelphia's
July 4th parade.
So, here they are
marching down the street.
An image of the Dalai Lama,
as if he's being carried
in a carriage, and this is
Yak, the national animal,
considered the national
animal of Tibet.
Two people are in it dancing,
and then, there's a line
of women behind the
carriage dancing
to recorded Tibetan music.
And here's Losong, the artist
I mentioned at the beginning
at work, creating a mandala.
So, I mentioned to you a
few things that Tibetans
in Philadelphia do on an annual
basis, but on a monthly basis,
they meet on a Wednesday evening
to actually teach their
own community about Tibet,
to intentionally speak Tibetan,
eat Tibetan food,
wear Tibetan clothes.
Maybe they show a
documentary or bring in a guest
with some special knowledge.
This is a time that they
are nonviolently working
to counter the cultural
oppression in their homeland.
And Losong here,
creating the sand mandala,
says that as he brings these
images to life, he considers
that his own lahkar, his
own way to counter that kind
of cultural oppression,
and as he's making this,
people come around to watch, and
he has a chance to talk to them,
not only about Buddhist
philosophy, but about Tibet
and other aspects
of his culture.
Once a week, they
gather for Sunday school.
The kids are learning to read
and write and speak Tibetan,
which many of them do at
home, and learning dances
and songs and prayers, as well.
And every day, in the
privacy of their own homes,
they pay respects to the
Buddha and to the Dalai Lama.
So, that was an example
of one kind of folk arts
and social change residency
that we developed together
with members of the community.
That's a tiny community,
150 people,
and another community we spent
years and years getting to know
and developing relationships
with is a little bit bigger.
It's 15,000 to 25,000 people,
and that's the Liberian
community of Philadelphia.
It's hard to know exact numbers.
Philadelphia has one of the
highest populations of Liberians
in the United States, and it's
been our pleasure and honor
to work with artists
from that community.
And we're going to show you a
movie that is, in some ways,
a combination of an
initiative that we've had going
for a few years, and we'll
be happy to talk to you
about that afterwards.
As a way to introduce the movie,
I'd like to introduce you to one
of the stars of it,
Fatu Gayflor.
[ Applause ]
>> Fatu Gayflor:
Hello, everybody.
At this time, I just
want to welcome everybody
to this beautiful
afternoon to watch our movie.
I just ask you to sit tight
and watch every bit
that we have for you.
We are very, very proud
that we brought our stories.
When the stories is in
you, it hurts a lot.
But when you put it
out, it helps a lot.
So, we took this time to work
with Philadelphia
Folklore Project to be able
to put our stories out, so
that people know who we are
in the inside and
on the outside.
So, I hope you enjoy,
and thank you for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> Voiceover: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.